you know how you should live life
what if today on your drive home you get
into an accident and you die
what would you do if you knew you had 30
minutes left so so let me get this
straight for the people that give that
message so you mean to tell me you want
to have me spend the rest of my life as
if I'm gonna die in the next 30 minutes
because if I knew I'm gonna die in the
next 30 minutes I'm not on this podcast
tonight right right hey neither are you
right we're elsewhere you're hanging out
with your mom and dad with your family
yeah you know you're with people that
you love your your new girl you're you
know your Adam's probably out there you
know doing what he's doing